dans cette forêt des laurentides eu des
milliers de être son empire il andré
goulet un ingénieur forestier constate
une épidémie grandissante de la maladie
corticale
un insecte la cochenille s'attaque à
l'arbre et propage un champignon qui tue
le être lentement pendant plusieurs
années un phénomène présent dans le sud
du québec et en ontario qui peut
déstabiliser l'écosystème des espèces
comme l'ours noir qui vont se nourrir
abondamment des femmes les femmes ce
sont les petites noix produite par leur
être et donc la disparition du règne du
paysage vraiment alter l'habitat pour
l'ours noir les maladies n'est pas
nouvelle mais elle progresse rapidement
ça existe depuis longtemps s'étaient
produits en nouvelle écosse
à la fin des années 18 cents mais ca
progresser très lentement vers l'est des
années 60 au québec maintenant c'est
rendu de notre côté de montréal
québec et laurent
caroline collin et se décrit comme une
amoureuse des arbres sur son terrain à
saint colomban dans les laurentides
elle voit la racine de l'ancien être une
[ __ ] et essayer attaqué dans le
passé oui oui ça me fait peur toutes ces
maladies le qui commença il commence sur
un arbre puis l'oeil et ross tout comme
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec lui ce
qui se passe encore avec le frame aucun
traitement n'existe encore pour protéger
ce type d'arbre ou le guérir on voit
vraiment que les écosystèmes sont très
perturbés c'est pas fini europe d'autres
d'autres espèces exotiques envahissantes
qui cognent à la porte dont le
longicorne asiatique qui cible plusieurs
fûts dont les rames lassus qu'imaginer
pour andré goule et la solution est
simple diversifier les populations
dambre dans les forêts pour augmenter
leur résilience face aux changements des
écosystèmes ici charlotte dumoulin radio
canada après votants et laurentides